there's a guy named stephen wolfram
there's a concept called cellular
automata
so there's a there's some mysteries
in these um systems that are
computational in nature that
have maybe echoes of the kind of
mysteries we should
need to solve to understand what is life
[Music]
so if we could talk take a
computational view of things do you
think there's something compelling to
reducing everything down to computation
like the universe is computation
and then trying to understand life so
throw away the biology throw away the
chemistry throw away even the physics
that you
you learn undergrad in graduate school
and more look at these simple little
systems
whether it's cellular automata or
whatever the heck kind of computational
systems that operate on simple local
rules
and then create complexity as they
evolve
is is it uh at all you think productive
to focus on those kinds of systems to
get an
inkling of what is life and if it is
do you do you think it's it's possible
to come up with some kind of laws
and principles about what makes life in
those computational
systems so i like cellular automata i
think they're good toy models um
but mostly like where i've thought about
them and use them is to actually
um let's say
poke at sort of the current conceptual
framework that we have and see where the
flaws are
um so i think like the part that you're
talking about that people find
intriguing is that if you have like a
fairly simple rule
and you specify some initial condition
and you run that rule and that initial
condition you could get really complex
patterns emerging and ooh doesn't that
look lifelike
um yeah yeah well it's like really
surprising isn't it
it is really surprising and they're
beautiful um and
i i think they have a lot of nice
features associated to them
um i think the things that i find yeah
so
so i i do think um as a proof of
principle
that you can get complex things emerging
from simple rules they're great
um as a sort of proof of principle about
some of the ways that we might think
of computation as being sort of a
fundamental
principle for dynamical systems and
maybe the evolution of the universe as a
whole
they're a great model system as an
explanatory framework for life
i think they're a bit problematic for
the same reason
that the laws of physics are a bit
problematic
um and the clearest way i can articulate
that
is like cellular automata are actually
cast
in sort of a conceptual framework for
how the universe should be described
that goes all the way back
to newton in fact with this idea that
we can have a fixed law of motion which
exists
sort of it's given to you you know the
great programmer in the sky gave you
this
equation or this rule and then you just
run with it
um and the rule doesn't have so a good
feature of the rule
is it doesn't have specified in the rule
information about the patterns it
generates so
you wouldn't want for example the my cup
or my water bottle
or you know me sitting here to be
specified in the laws of physics that
would be ridiculous because it wouldn't
be a very simple explanation of all
things happening i'd have to explain
everything
so and tell your time to have that
feature um and the laws of physics have
that feature
um but but you know you also need to
specify the initial condition
um and it also it basically means that
everything that happens
is sort of a consequence of that initial
condition and i think
this kind of framework is just not the
right one for
biology and part of the way that it's
easiest to see this
is um a lot of people talk about
self-reference being important
in life the fact that you know like the
genome
has information encoded in it that
information gets read out
it specifies something about the
architecture of a cell
the architecture of the cell includes
the genome so the genome has basically
self-referential information
self-reference obviously comes up in
computational law because it's kind of
foundational
to turing's work and what girdle did
with the incompleteness theorems and
things so there's a lot of um
parallels there and people have talked
about that at depth
you